форми для вагітних досить часто Люди
дивуються і кажуть як цього вагітність
що воюють Ну я їм пояснюю вагітність
звичайно не воюють Вони знаходяться в
штабах частина - це можуть бути юристи
діловоди кадри фінансисти бухгалтери це
можуть бути і бойові спеціалізація Але
звичайно жінка вже не при виконанні
бойового завдання але трудового
законодавство для військових і цивільних
воно однакове і за статутом жінка
повинна ходити на роботу до сьомого
місяця вагітності в статутній військовій
формі Ну мені трошки складно уявити як
можна на сьомому місяці вагітності і
ходити в формі яка не передбачена
конкретно для вагітних станом на 2021
рік в Збройних силах України було більше
ніж 2 000 вагітних ну Уявіть собі 2000
жінок а форми для вагітних у них не
виглядають Це просто великі розмір але
він передбачає цілковиту зручність і
Комфорт для того щоб навіть 9-го місяця
Якщо необхідно